[MUSIC PLAYING]
It was my privilege 26 years
ago to award you your bachelor's
degree, and 25 years ago,
your master's degree.
It was soon recognized that
your first-rate performance
as a teacher was matched
by first-rate talent
as an administrator.
And you were quickly co-opted
from one administrative job
after another.
In fact, you hardly
had the opportunity
to warm the chair in
one post before you
were drafted for another.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's very nice to
have so many people
from so many institutions and
so many old friends who've
come back today to participate
in this celebration.
I got to know Paul Gray when I
was beginning graduate school.
But we really became close
when I became his provost.
I first met him through
his deep involvement
in undergraduate
education at MIT.
He was a great friend,
a great colleague,
but also a very
great teacher for me.
I got involved as an athlete--
as a swimmer, as
rower, as a sailor.
And I would often see him
and I would invite him
to our competitions.
And he would come.
And I remember he and Priscilla
coming in to a swimming meet,
and just sitting down, and
staying for the whole time.
He was a quietly very
brave, tenacious man,
loving and kind and
gentle and very focused
and always very engaged.
He loved being around experts,
and taking advice from experts,
and learning from experts,
and sharing with experts.
He was the father who took
us hiking, biking, swimming,
sailing, skating.
He's the one who
ran behind us when
we were learning to ride our
bikes until we could do it
on our own.
There were no training wheels.
You just figured it out.
Paul began his MIT
life as a freshman.
Paul came to MIT in 1950,
so that's almost 70 years.
That's just simply remarkable.
I cannot think of anybody else
who gave so much of his life,
who shared so much of his
life with this institute.
He's a very
down-to-earth individual.
Very straightforward
man but very caring.
He did so much for MIT.
And he did it loyally.
He did it morning,
noon, and night.
He was so devoted to this
place and to the students
in such a genuine way.
He was never in it for himself.
He was always in it for MIT.
Some years ago, in a
commencement in the rain,
a father was heard to say,
'after the soaking I've taken
for the last four years,
who minds a little rain?'
[LAUGHTER AND CHEERING]
But I have to say,
this is something else.
In the competitive
sport of diving,
the various dives
are ranked according
to the degree of difficulty.
When the performances of
different divers are equal,
the diver who chooses
the dive with the highest
degree of difficulty wins.
Now by that measure alone,
you here today are winners.
You have chosen and
successfully negotiated
a collegiate education having
what may be the nation's
highest degree of difficulty.
[CHEERING]
He always called it
this special place.
And I think for him, it
really was a special place
and a kind of home
unlike he'd ever
had before because it
satisfied him intellectually,
and it satisfied him,
I think, emotionally.
And when he was able to
connect his own family to it,
then I think that that
was sort of a full circle.
MIT is best known for the
scientists and engineers
who have studied there.
He was at MIT at a time when
engineering changed completely
from a largely empirical
practice of making
things and making them
work to a situation
where science and understanding
fundamentals affected
the design and the
implementation of so
many systems.
This very gentle, quiet, fierce
man I know had to do battle
to get Whitehead
Institute established.
People were terribly suspicious.
And you know, frankly, he
wasn't sure what it would be.
Nobody was.
It was an experiment.
And he took the risk.
[CRACK]
[CHEERING]
MIT and the biomedical
enterprise in Kendall Square
is unrivaled anywhere
in the world.
And so I do credit Paul
with setting us out
in that direction.
So the Whitehead.
We now have the
Broad, and the Ragon,
the Koch Institute-- any
number of expressions
of the power of biology
to transform our world.
When I came to MIT,
which was in 1965,
I think maybe 2 or 3
percent of the students
were women, fewer than
that on the faculty.
It was very much a
male institution.
He was tremendously
committed to diversity,
increasing the
representation in the faculty
and in the student body of
women and of minorities.
The number of entering African
American students at MIT
went from about 3
to 5 per year to 57.
To this day, I mean, we're just
very proud of that momentum
that Paul brought to
the table on this issue.
MIT has a responsibility
to itself and to the nation
to be open and
indeed to reach out
to the most talented and
promising people, regardless
of race or sex.
[APPLAUSE]
None of us created all
the bias around us.
But we certainly inherit it.
And what I love
about President Gray
is that he stepped
right into that.
And as soon as he saw
it and understood it,
he decided to actually
do something about it.
[MUSIC - AARON COPLAND, "FANFARE
FOR THE COMMON MAN"]
During his inauguration,
what he wanted
as the walking-in music was
Aaron Copland's "Fanfare
for the Common Man."
And that was him, you know?
He always was in touch with
his very modest beginnings
in a blue-collar family, where
the economy was a challenge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of his fraternity
brothers, while he
was at MIT as a sophomore,
was dating a woman
at Wheaton College, where
my mother was a freshman.
They introduced
my parents on what
turned out to be a rather
successful blind date.
It was very cold.
And they're walking
across the bridge,
and my mother doesn't
have any gloves.
And my father said, 'I've
got a pair of gloves.
Why don't we do this.
I'll wear the left one.
You wear the right one.
And we'll hold hands to
keep the middle ones warm.'
And they walked
across the bridge,
and they walked off
into the future.
That was the first day
of their relationship.
I thought, well, that's pretty
good for a nerd from New
Jersey.
A very clever use of a pair of
gloves to win the girl's heart.
It was the big blizzard of '78.
And no cars were allowed
on the road for a week.
But MIT was not
going to shut down.
So we started this bus line.
And one of my favorite pictures
of Paul Gray is with his big
wolf skin or beaver skin hat--
you know, like a Russian hat--
out in the parking lot
at MIT where the buses
came in, directing traffic.
I mean, he was
very much hands on.
He looks incredibly happy,
actually, in the picture.
He was just doing what
he could do, I think,
and having fun doing it.
I think he had a lot
of joy in what he did.
He was a real proponent of
the Undergraduate Research
Opportunities Program, UROP.
It was dramatically
successful and found
a way for undergraduates to
interact with the faculty
in their research project.
This would be a way
in which students
could, for the first time
perhaps in their years at MIT,
come to terms with an unsolved
real problem, something
where they could make
a genuine contribution.
That became an integral part
of how MIT educates students.
So it was a huge thing for us.
When we finished up all the
administrative and leadership
roles that he had at MIT, he
went back to the classroom.
He loved being in the classroom.
You turn the crank on
a three-by-three matrix
and solve for the node voltages
e sub b, e sub c, and e sub d.
He was an absolutely
excellent teacher.
Clarity, complete concern with
the students' understanding.
Very much enjoyed
being in their company.
Professor Gray was
my academic adviser
when I was an
undergrad here at MIT.
And I remember he was a
really warm, very friendly,
giving adviser.
At first, maybe
you would think it
might be a little intimidating,
having your adviser be
the ex-president of MIT.
But that turned out not
to be the case at all.
Professor Gray was
extremely down to earth.
He really understood
technological education,
and what a technological
research university is really
about, and how precious it is.
One of the many involvements
that the Grays had
with students were
the senior dinners.
We invited the whole class to
dinner, 60 or 70 at a time.
All of us at MIT, we just
celebrate the opportunities
to be with those students.
They are so special.
Every semester on Registration
Day, we would meet with him.
And then that evening, all
of us-- all of his advisees--
would go out to dinner with
him, always at the Royal East.
You can imagine, there
was a big table, usually
in the back of the restaurant,
all filled with I'd say maybe
about 10 or so advisees.
Yours is the obligation to help
heal this society where healing
is required, to help strengthen
the nations where strengthening
is required, and to
help bring harmony
among the nations of this
world, wherever discord obtains.
If you have ever seen Paul's
official presidential portrait,
it is a portrait of
Paul and Priscilla.
He was the first person to
have his spouse in the picture,
right?
And I think that,
for him, that was
a measure of his
devotion for her,
his appreciation
for all the things
that my mother may have
sacrificed in order to help
him have the roles and the
opportunities that he had,
and all the ways in
which she supported him.
I think that that was
his way of saying,
I wouldn't have been able to
do this without Priscilla.
It was extraordinary
to watch them together,
how they worked together, how
they supported each other.
They both had a
twinkle in their eye
that would kind of ping at you.
Just to know that there was
someone sort of watching over
us, making sure that things
generally are probably
going to be OK for
us, so I really
appreciated that very much.
He is a man of
exceptional integrity.
The humanness of the
man and of Priscilla
was so essential to the kind of
leadership he provided at MIT.
He cared about people.
A person with
tremendous integrity,
a person with tremendous
wisdom, thoughtful, calm.
An extraordinarily
forceful person
but also with a surprisingly
gentle personality.
He was good at listening.
He was good at negotiating
and meeting people partway.
And he was good at imagining
what might be possible
if this shifted or that changed
or we could move forward
together in this direction.
As you undertake this
next stage in your lives,
I wish for you a life that
is rich in opportunities
to stretch your talents, your
interests, your imagination,
and your vision of
this small planet
as a beautiful oasis,
generating peace.
And as you depart from
this special place,
I wish you Godspeed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]